Customers are getting confused.
It may be cultural or just different personalities.
But, I need to make sure everybody speaks up when they have something to offer.
Some speak quite easily...
...but others need encouragement and they really appreciate being heard.
Sometimes, I try to pull someone in with a compliment...
...or a comment on their experience with the issue.
Or maybe I just beg for their help.
Kida, the purchasing department seems to have figured out a way...
...to use the new part numbers.
Can you explain your workaround?
Sure. So, we saw that the website upgrade appended an extra field to each SKU.
We tried running a conversion which seemed to work fine.
But, we see it only as a temporary solution.
So, it sounds like the best solution is to add the 01 to the end.
Then, when I'm sure everyone has had their say, it's time to end the meeting.
Listen guys, the time is almost up.
Let me review what we've come up with for today.
I always try to end with a positive statement of what we accomplished or agreed on.
While concluding, I'll summarize, assign action steps or schedule the next meeting.
Thanks, everybody. I'll see you all again on Friday...
...when we've had the chance to implement and test these fixes.
See you then.
Goodbye, everyone!